[Music]
you know when i was asked to host the
canadian screen awards
i called my good friend chris rock and i
said to him
i've got some great news chris i'm going
to canada and he said
i've got some great news too i'm hosting
the oscars what are you doing in canada
and i said you know visiting some family
friends
the usual and i want everyone in america
right now to look at me
look at me smoking indoors
i didn't ask anybody i just did it what
are they gonna do kick me out before i
get the prize
no [ __ ] this is called leverage
also not nominated i love you philip
morris um
jim jim carrey and euro mcgregor two
heterosexual actors
pretending to be gay so the complete
opposite of some famous scientologist
then
um
probably why the [ __ ] will we force-fed
a meal at 4pm
like this thing isn't televised just
start it later who gives a [ __ ]
has has anyone looked at their gift bag
is three magazines and a bottle of water
[Applause]
everyone who's won the ward is from that
corner
they know who's going to win just sit
them here let's speed this thing up
and there has been a definite lack of
diversity in the presenters
me and mimi driver are the only foreign
people and let's be honest
we don't look that diverse
anyway
or this is an exciting award look at
kevin hart
look at kevin hart thank you jesus
i just want to say it because every time
you say it people go crazy thank you
jesus
[Applause]
mr don prickles mr chairman
ladies and gentlemen why did they stand
was it jewish holiday
no because you're a legend don because
you're you
that was very sweet of you folks to
stand next time just leave a check by
the door i think
uplifting the community thank you jesus
is what the hoodie he is real
[Applause]
he is real
thank you jesus thank you very much
i'm very excited to be here you know and
i was asked to uh host the espys this
year
yeah hi that's my name esme
i was asked to host the espys this year
folks i said yes
immediately for one reason and one
reason only
this show has interns
[Applause]
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long
leonardo dicaprio attended the premiere
and by the end
his date was too old for him
to improve the lives of those they serve
jesus served too
thank you jesus all right in a minute
kevin seriously what is the key i just
want to say that jesus
is in my life thank you jesus shirley
[Applause]
oh my god one is a community activist
for children
i was gonna go to the strip club but i'm
not gonna go because jesus is here
[Applause]
but man it's great to be here the sixth
annual espy award it's hard to believe
now that the espys are six
years old although uh
[Applause]
although anthony mason swears they're
18. so
yeah he'll be having sex with the espys
in about 12 years so
marty when we see all the films you did
none of them were great
no no i look around the room and i
realize now
aside from clint eastwood i'm the
biggest name here
clint eastwood is now thrilled his name
was mentioned
and there was also some confusion about
whether or not it was an award or
a prize and i and actually it's an award
even though they call it the prize it's
an award because usually when there's a
prize
there's money involved
[Applause]
i thought i was gonna get some paper i
was like yo
mark twain awarded kennedy said that
sound like paper
then they told me yesterday they raised
2.3 million i was like yo
i'm in there
i came down and they told me that dude
oh there is no
it's it's a it's a prize but it's just
there's no money and i was like
so i think to clear up the confusion for
future recipients
maybe maybe maybe you don't want to call
it the
mark twain prize maybe you might want if
you don't want to call it the award
maybe you could call it the mark twain
surprise
earn college scholarships
what are you doing i'm about to thank
jesus again
i just want to say it all the time
kurt look at me kurt
no one cares about movers anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv
everyone's watching netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we got
to drag it out for three hours
you could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife
instead of watching this show that
that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer
and it's still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end
he obviously didn't kill himself just
like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
[Applause]
just backstage a lot of celebrities back
there man i was talking to jerry jones
you know the cowboys owner and uh he's
disappointed obviously
yeah well he's a good guy though man
he's talking about rebuilding the team
you know and he told me he says
we have to get back to what made us a
championship team
strippers and crack
dinero is sitting there god bless you
bob he's got the beard on
to know him is a treat he's one of the
great actors of our time you ask him
uh trinity leader
with the keys of the 2008 that's me
that's me right there
that's me i'm reading it watch out watch
out everybody move this is my part
no no no y'all gotta step back everybody
step back
okay
[Applause]
hey steve did you you see me do kurt
franklin with one leg